Who's the puppiest wuppiest wuppy?
Uh oh. Here we go.
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Sophie's Curse.
I've actually got buddy in the room here with me,
you can't see her but she's breathing into the microphone right now.
Aren't you, you sweet little pup?
And she's gonna keep me safe,
through this horrible nightmare of everything that's going wrong in this house.
So, I was trying to think...
Um..
about how to do better at this game.
And that didn't work out very well,
because my brain is not very good at the think-doing.
Isn't that right Puppy?
Uh, oh. Chica's running away, cause she thinks
I'm yelling at her probably.
She's not used to me
talking so loudly to no one in particular!
I mean, I'm talking to you guys, but to her I might as well be talking to no one.
God damnit.
I've forgotten where the buttons are, where you push things to go places...
Gersh dernit!
I'm trying to find where the safe room is!
I...a-f-f F**k!
Thank you, Chica.
She brought me a bone.
Chica, you wanna say hi?
Uh, oh. Here we go.
Ech.
Aahhaha
Chica, say hi!
"Hello."
Wave your paw.
"Hello!"
Hi Chica. Who's a good puppy?
Say hi to the audience!
*awkward silence*
Oookay, nevermind then!
Alright.
Chica's go- *stuttering*
I'm gonna put Chica down, cause she, uh...
She doesn't seem to like that very much.
Oh no, she's fine!
CHICA, IT'S OKAY!
I KNOW, IT'S A SCARY GAME!
Ooooooga booga!
Aaaand she's under my feet right now..
Aw, she's so cute.. ANYWAY, back to this.
So, I was trying to think of how best to do this game,
- aaand I couldn't come up with a strategy.
And I was trying to read comments, but most of the
comments in the last video were just..
people talking about the jumpscares, and where they
were, so that they-they could avoid them.
What's the point of..
watching a horror game if you're gonna just avoid all the
- the.. jumpscares.
That was the right button!
I was trying to click somewhere else, and it wasn't
working. Okay, so the save point is at..
A!
Oddly enough. That's good!
Because that means that I'm near the safe point at the bottom
and I don't have to up and sleep with grandma...
grandpa
grandma-pa
It's both!
It's both merfed into one body!
MERFED!
Chica it got merfed!
Okay anyway...
Uh oh, that doesn't sound good.
Ah f- ah fuuu... I'm outta here baby!
F**k
Where am I go- NO! Don't go upstairs!
I was't trying to go upstairs. I was trying to go back to the safe point.
Can I go back to the frickin' safe point?
Thank you.
I don't know what happened but this is something good.
Okay...
So the save point is here.
I know that for a fact.
And I know that I'm supposed to
be listening out for a creepy noise
of some sort
whenever I'm charging these things
and I'm supposed to stop immediately.
But it's not incredibly obvious!
Oh my God.
Chica just rubbed by my l-
I think that might've been the creepy noise.
Ooh, I heard like a...
a...
th- something crying.
rrg
I don't like it.
I don't like it much at aAALLL
F**K ME WHAT WAS I SUPPOSED TO DO?!!
Ahh, what was I supposed to do???
What was I supposed to do-
quick guide!
"Sophie can be pretty mean."
I'M AWARE OF THAT!
I'M AWAARRREEE!
So...
*sassy cough*
I guess if Sophie appears in front of me like that
I need to figure out a better way to
OH MY GOD I'M SORRY!
Oh Chica-Bica, I'm so sorry!
Chica!
Don't run away!
I'm sorry!
I accidentally
I-
I
...cross my legs sometimes when I'm sitting down.
I think I kicked her in the face.
I'm sorry, Chica-Bica!
Aawwww
Okay
Aw man!
It's all the way up with Grandpa again!
I never feel safe
when I'm standing outside of Grandpa's door
staring in all creepily!
In fact, I don't know how Grandpa feels safe!
I mean, I'm pretty sure
this isn't exactly MY grandpa.
Eh, whatever.
It's gonna work out!
It's gonna work out fine!
I wonder what would happen if Chi-
if Chica was with me in this environment.
Grandpa, Grandpa, Grandpa!
I hear a strange noise, Grandpa!
Oh F**k! OK
Ahh how do I do?!
*silence*
Ahh frick. I need to put up the guides for the buttons.
How do I put them back up?
Aahhhhhhhh.
How do I put 'em back up??
I wanna put up my dukes.
So I can at least defend against this horrible ghoost.
I gotta get to at least ten am..pm
Right? I don't know.
Ah god dammit. Why's it always up with grandpa
I ruin my one opportunity to have my safe-point by the kitchen with all the beer.
Not that I can drink beer anymore becuase I'd DIE.
My heart would exploode apparently.
*cranking sound* gotta crank this yank*cranking continues*